اذا اليوم اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان
له ان مقاتليه ياخذون المعارك الاعنف
والاكثر شده في قطاع غزه منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه البريه داخل القطاع هناك تطورات
كثيره سنبدا من احدث هذه التطورات في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه هي بؤره اشتباك رئيسيه
واساسيه ما زلنا نتحدث عن خانيونس وهي قلب
المعارك في جنوب قطاع غزه اليوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال ان وحدات من اللواء الرابع
تقوم
بتمشيط شرق وغرب وعده مناطق محيطه في
خانيونس وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه عثر
على ما قال انها انفاق تستخدموا لتصنيع
الاسلحه تابعه لكتائب القسام وانه
تعانى بجنود من وحده يا هالوم وهي وحده
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انها متخصصه في كشف
وتدمير الانفاق هذا ما قالته اسرائيل لكن
كتائب القسام قالت انها استهدفت اكثر من
موقع للجيش الاسرائيلي لا سما في مناطق
شرق خانيونس وانها اشتبكت معهم في اكثر من
مكان وايضا كتائب السرايا القدس قالت انها
استهدفت اليات عسكريه تابعه لقوات
الاحتلال في المنطقه الجنوبيه في خانيونس
خلال اشتباكات اليوم طبعا الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان اعلن عن مقتل جنديين له
واصابه اكثر من 38 في المعارك وشهدت
الطائرات المروحيه الاسرائيليه تخلي
الجرحى باتجاه مستشفيات بئر السبع في
صحراء نقب من المنطقه الشماليه المنطقه
الشماليه ايضا ما زالت تشهد قصفا ولكن
القصف يتركز في اكثر من محور في جباليا
البلد هناك قصف اسرائيلي مكثف كتائب
القسام استهدفت قوه اسرائيليه في مخيم
جباليا لكن اللافت اليوم هو ما يجري في حي
الشيخ رضوان قبل ايام كانت قوات الاحتلال
نفذت انسحابات من تل الهواء ودوار فلسطين
في مدينه غزه لكن اليوم الشيخ رضوان هو حي
غرب ايه قطاع غزه طبعا قريب من مخيم
الشاطئ لا تتجاوز مساحه الحي كيلومترين
ونصف مربعين انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه من
شرق حي الشيخ رضوان اما المناطق الجنوبيه
لحي الشيخ رضوان ما زالت تشهد اشتباكات
واسعه وايضا هناك عمليات عسكريه استهدافات
لكتائب القسام وايضا لسرايا القدس وما
تزال كامل المنطقه ال الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
تشهد اشتباكات مع التذكير بالقصف العنيف
في مخيمات جنوب قطاع غزه نقطه اخيره ان
كتائب القسام اليوم و سرايا القدس تمكنوا
من اطلاق صواريخ من داخل قطاع غزه استهدفت
مستوطنات الغلاف هذه ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه زين اكيد للتحليل معك و اللواء
الدويري بالفعل